this is pal
he's the friendly sort of giant robot
this 20-foot tall machine helps make
flight possible you know when you're on
an aeroplane and you look out of the
window and you think to yourself all
that's keeping me in the air here is
some clever aerodynamics over that
equally clever wing with you're on a 737
this is where those wings are made wings
end up beautifully complex but they
start very simply they're hollow they're
like a piece of corrugated cardboard or
maybe a wall in your house there's a top
and bottom sheet and then ribs or struts
between them the void in the middle is
actually the fuel tank so everything has
to be joined together perfectly what
this line does it builds up our upper
and lower wing panels that build up our
wing box on our 737 wing at the rates
we're at right now we install 44,000
fasteners a day what we're just building
42 airplanes a month right now so two
sets of right left hands every single
day and that is where a good old Powell
comes in the panel assembly line is a
robotic update to the age-old process of
clamping drilling and then riveting
wings together by hand
our legacy lines been around since the
1960s in the new assembly line we have
about 90% of the fasteners are installed
by the machine it's a lot easier on the
workers now they don't have to practice
their yoga to reach the furthest corners
or risk repetitive strain injuries nine
Powell machines in total will allow
Boeing's build wings in a continuous
flow twice as fast as it used to
lasers guide the machine for maximum
precision when joining wing panels
together with fasteners it can follow
the panel's curvature but it's the scale
here that's really impressive when
you're building a 737 with a total
wingspan of over a hundred feet it
really helps to have some pretty big
friends on your side
you